[Music]
you know our narrator has some strong
opinions about movies and a heavy
reliance on swearing but did you know he
had his own YouTube channel of course
you didn't
it only launched today but he does and
if you want to hear what he has to say
about movies in a completely uncensored
way head over and check it out and yeah
we mean uncensored those of you who hate
that we bleeped the cuss words are gonna
love it over there
he doesn't censorship he's starting with
a letter-writing campaign called dear
Hollywood sharing some observations and
advice but who knows what all kinds of
crazy she'll get into over there so
again check it out or don't but why
wouldn't you I mean are you busy you got
the big plans
why aren't you clicking yet why don't
you go home ball are you too good for
your home why are you still not clicking
why am i referring to myself in the
third person
[Music]